on fuel
but inspiration
is the fuel
that drives nasa
and indeed
drives humanity
so
this novel innovation that made webb
possible is exactly why nasa and why
humanity continues
to push
the envelope as the test pilots say
push the edge of the envelope
nasa's no stranger to first steps and as
we enter this new era of space flight
and discovery we need to be bold
we have to take risk
but the reward
is worth the risk
and this is proof of that
it represents the largest international
space science program
it collaborates internationally
now
michelle i'm going to turn it back over
to you
to share messages from our international
partners thank you so much
the mission would not be as successful
as it is today without the teamwork and
contributions from our mission partners
the european space agency and the
canadian space agency we are pleased to
share with you a special video message
from esa's director general dr joseph
oshbacher and their director of science
kunta hazinga
the james webb space telescope is such a
fantastic opportunity it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity which we
have here and uh we are so excited both
good myself
on this first data release it will
really change the understanding of our
universe but uh before i head over to
winter just one word this is also a
symbol of
international cooperation the
partnership with with nasa is
outstanding it's uh it's really
exciting but really fantastic and also
with csa the canadian space agency and
this is more than science it's also a
symbol of international partnership but
good
a bit more about the james webb space
telescope what this means thank you very
much joseph yeah this is the day that we
have all been waiting for for so long
and now now it's happening
you know james webb is a fantastic
machine and um infrared eyes are three
times sharper than the hubble space
telescope and they're a hundred times
more sensitive so with these infrared
eyes you can peer into dark obscured
regions in our universe you can look at
the very first phases of the universe
after the big bang you can look at
planets in our own solar system and then
around other stars
and it is indeed a once-in-a-lifetime
chance almost like the moon landing for
astronomy and it will actually feed many
many careers it has already shaped a
whole new generation of scientists and
this will continue
it's a masterpiece for international
cooperation as josef had said
we are working with nasa and the
canadian space agency and this is
actually in tradition to hubble to
cassini-huygens
where nada is leading and esa is
partnering but we are also opposite uh
having missions where isa is leading and
nasa is partnering
like for instance
colombo jews
the euclid spacecraft and so on
so esa the science program is actually
enabling the european scientists to lead
in a number of discrete fields and one
of the important fields is for instance
astrometry with gaia where we are really
having a leadership position and now
james webb james webb will answer a lot
of questions even some questions which
we do not even know about yet talking of
nasa and what we do here i mean of
course we have many contributions in the
change web space telescope
we have instruments one and a half
instruments that we are providing we
have a science team that is working with
nasa and the other partners but one
event was very special and which was the
launch of the james webb on christmas
day from coho onlarian5 and this was
really a very important event for us not
only is nasa entrusting this james
webster's telescope to us
visa but also the insertion of the james
webb space telescope into orbit was so
precise that scientists have a much
longer lifetime of the james webb space
telescope actually doubled the lifetime
and this is really fantastic because
this really shows also that our space
transportation technology in addition to
the science so technology is just
outstanding and very proud and very
happy about that so go webco go by go
[Music]
our next video is from the canadian
space agency and this is from the
president lisa campbell
hello everyone today marks a major
milestone in the webb space telescope
mission as we're about to witness webb's
unprecedented view of the universe
webb promises to be the next giant leap
in space astronomy we're confident that
the observatory will exceed expectations
bold important missions like this are
only possible through strong
international collaboration this
one-of-a-kind mission is a testament to
what we can achieve when we work
together and web is truly a global
effort congratulations to our partners
nasa and the european space agency
thousands of brilliant minds around the
world are behind the design launch and
operation of this complex space
telescope
the canadian space agency is honored to
be part of web canadian specialists
across industry and academia united
their efforts to provide our instruments
canada's fine guidance sensor will keep
webb perfectly aligned during all of its
observations
and the nearest instrument will observe
the earliest galaxies and perform
in-depth analysis of the most promising
exoplanets
for the science community in canada and
across the world having access to data
collected by web will lead to unexpected
discoveries
web will not only help us work out
long-awaited answers to age-old
questions it will also inspire new
cutting-edge research that leads the way
to our cosmic origins
congratulations to all who made these
imminent discoveries possible
if
if it wasn't for years of steadfast
congressional support this extraordinary
project wouldn't have been able to get
off the ground so it's fitting that we
have representatives from team merlin
joining us and let me clarify these
gentlemen are not just representatives
they are friends of nasa goddard
[Music]
please join me in welcoming maryland's
5th congressional district majority
leader of the united states house of
representatives steny hoyer senator ben
cardin senator chris van hollen and the
representative trone from maryland's
david trone from maryland's 6th
congressional district
thank you very much michelle it's good
to be here with astronaut nelson
so sorry you're sick andrew
all of us have fought
hubble was at risk
goddard was at risk
webb was at risk
this day
this day gives a new meaning
to as far
as the eye can see
the vision
of the world is greater today than it
was yesterday
and it will redown to the benefit of all
the peoples of this earth
what a wonderful day i want all of you
who have worked on this project to stand
up
stand up
all right
you're using our time
america thanks you
and the world community
thanks you
our time is short let me yield to the
senior senator from the unit
from maryland my dear friend ben carton
who has fought so hard along with
barbara mikulski to make this day happen
thank you stenny
how many times have i said that i could
really mean it this time
we are so
that proud has played you heard michelle
and all the different organizations and
government agencies and institution and
private
so many are located in maryland stunning
already acknowledged the incredible
workforce we know the 20th century will
be known for space exploration by neil
armstrong
the 21st century he will be led by the
work done by the james webb telescope
this is an incredible moment
it's now
back to the future and we're going to be
part of it
chris van gaal
well it's great to be back here at
goddard and thank all of you who have
been part of this team you know you've
made it when you have your own
cheerleading squad
as somebody who was uh briefly a physics
major but bailed out after quantum
mechanics i want to thank all the
scientists and the engineers and
everybody who stuck with it to bring us
to this brilliant day this is a great
day for humanity peering further back
into time deeper into our universe
answering some questions that are
fundamental to who we are and how we got
here thank all of you from around the
world because this was an international
endeavor and while there were bumps
along the way once the launch happened
everything had to go perfectly and it
did because of all of you
i do want to say maryland is proud at
least on this day to be the center of
the universe and
thank you
thank you to goddard thank you to space
telescope
and we're going to continue to invest in
this mission and so many others along
with my friend david trone who's also on
the appropriations committee in the
house of representatives
[Music]
so thank you all very much for this
incredible moment in scientific history
and space exploration is what connects
us all and that's what's so fantastic
about it as the saying goes if you want
to go fast
but if you want to go far
go together and this team has gone
together so thank you and congrats
this telescope is by far the largest
science endeavor nasa has ever
undertaken and it required a huge
network of companies from around the
world to build it northrop grumman led
that team and helped nasa and
it's european and canadian partners to
achieve the success we see today to help
celebrate that success we have a special
message from northrup's ceo northrop
grumman ceo kathy borden
on behalf of the entire northrop grumman
team congratulations to the space and
science communities around the world on
what will be the first of many exciting
and truly historic web missions to come
these incredible images never before
seen by humankind
carry us further than we've ever gone
before and we're just getting started
the extraordinary telescope represents a
new era in human discovery and equally
important it represents the engineers
technicians scientists and the countless
other teams that have come together to
define possible
our work the technology we've created
and the images it captures will inspire
the next generation of thinkers
innovators and problem solvers
this is the true legacy of web
thank you and congratulations
as i said before it took companies from
around the world to get web in space
right now we're going to hear from the
ceo of aureon space staffon israel with
the message he would like to share with
you
webb
an incredible adventure we at ironspace
were honored to be part of a 20 years
collective challenge that finally
brought us together in korea with dr z
greg robinson joseph ashbarrer daniel
enschmander and philly baptist on a
christmas morning
we'll never forget
27 minutes and 11 seconds which will be
among the most important of our lives
after a perfect launch with our iron 5
which has doubled the web lifespan and
such a long journey we are now on the
verge of discovering images that will
revolutionize our understanding of the
universe
a game changer created by the collective
work of passionate and brilliant people
from usa europe and canada
to these dedicated teams i want to say
thank you thank you for your trust in
iran that made this incredible adventure
possible
go web
all right guys
we're only a few minutes away from
seeing the first images but before that
i would be remiss if we didn't take our
opportunity to let those that led the
way have an opportunity to say a few
things
we have the web program director greg
robinson north bremen's web program
manager scott willoughby and last but
certainly not least
the web project manager bill oaks
[Applause]
i'll just wing it uh so i will say when
i came up the stairs when by the time i
got to the top i wanted to throw off the
jacket and run out to the 50-yard line
so so thank you for that welcome i don't
know what i would have done when i got
there
so so who did not see that image
yesterday
as the old saying goes you ain't seen
nothing yet just hang around a little
bit longer i just want to do a couple of
quick thanks thank yous uh you've heard
from most of them thanks to the entire
team certainly the goddard led project
team
northrop
space telescope science institute and
our international partners
also i want to thank uh i called the 9th
floor the
nasa administrator and his team
and the white house and congress
all of us are part of this and when i
say team i mean everyone from beginning
to end and we all had to be aligned to
make this happen this thomas often
reminds me so thank thanks for all of
that i want to do a couple of special
thanks special thanks to scott
willoughby for leading the team out at
northrop bill oaks for leading the
overall team and i know both of them
will say more about their teams and the
capability of the spacecraft and a
special thank you to thomas i often say
twisting both of my arms to get me to
take over this
to be part of this incredibly smart and
resilient team so thank you and thanks
for coming
thank you
it's humbling to be here at goddard
my team from northrop grumman spent a
lot of time here and at many of the nasa
centers and other places around this
country but this is where relationships
were forged
and it's relationships that built the
james webb space telescope
and it's been a common theme here for a
purpose right the international
relationships the government the
government industry relationships but
the relationships that are dearest to me
are the ones that took place on the
floors of the high bays and in the
meeting rooms and debating hard problems
and sometimes those answers weren't
certain as much as engineering wants to
be and you're using judgment in people's
guts and brilliance to make decisions
that led to perfection
and what bill and i did throughout all
of this was really kind of singular it
was giving that team power and
i just kind of leave with a phrase that
i used back when we were getting into
the final build a web when people were
putting this together
that every human who touched this for
the last time should know
you get that privilege
and you get to bring your pride to the
floor to do that but you have to check
your ego
because pride is powerful but somebody's
gonna ask you a question did you do it
right and somebody's gonna look at a
picture when you did it and see was it
right and somebody else was going to
review that and stamp that it was right
and every single person mattered in that
and in the end it was perfect so thank
you and working with bill was really
relationships that's going to last a
lifetime over a decade i think we broke
the record for industry government
partnership we're not supposed to be
together for 10 years but we were
bill
thank you
well i guess i'm i'm the cleanup
typical job for a project manager
um first just a little update on the
observatory um over the weekend we
finished the last commissioning activity
so we are officially done with
commissioning
we have we have an observatory
that is in excellent shape that either
meets or exceeds requirements and as
mentioned earlier we have 20 plus years
of fuel on board
and finally we have actually started our
first year of normal science operations
and that is now in full swing
so as the old saying goes it takes a
village
with the web it actually took a town of
about 20 000 people
over a period of 20 plus years
across 29 u.s states and 14 countries
and even more if you add to that number
the the family the friends
the significant others etc who supported
webb
they are also part of that web team
you cannot really single out any one
person for the successive web but
everyone here should know that every
each image you are a part of that image
we would not be successful without your
contributions
to to the web program when i see these
images i see four things
i see dedication and i have never seen
dedication on this project like i have
seen on any other mission i have worked
i see personal sacrifice of so many
individuals
that my heart is just overwhelmed with
pride for the folks on this program
finally also i see passion i've never
seen the passion for this program and
that's what helps with the first two
things i mentioned
finally
i just see the faces of all our
individuals who have worked in this
program both the past and the present
and i can combine either myself nor nasa
will ever be able to think thank these
persons enough
and finally on a more personal note
the web team itself we're all going to
be bonded for the rest of our lives by
the web experience
and i have to thank you for the
privilege that you have allowed me to be
part of that experience thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you and congratulations
gentlemen and congratulations to all of
you once again
today we celebrate you and your
achievements now listen i'm sure you're
excited to see exactly what webb will
show us so here's the plan we're going
to take a quick break but as you
but as you all at home can see the
countdown clock we're literally minutes
away from the reveal are you all still
excited
it has been my absolute pleasure
spending this time with you we can't
wait to share what humankind is capable
of and we are just getting started let's
enjoy this journey now on the count of
three i want you all to scream go web
one
two
three
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
sky watchers this is it this is the day
we get the first science images back
from the james webb space telescope and
you've got a front row seat to the
cosmos
i'm michelle thaller your host what can
only be described as a celebration for
everyone on earth so think about this
light from the earliest days of the
universe has been traveling to us for
billions of years
just over the last few weeks we've
captured some of that light with the
telescope that sees the universe in an
entirely new way and today we share the
very first results
so longtime space fans are going to know
who this is this is dr john mather he's
the senior project scientist for the
webb telescope and a nobel prize winner
and john i couldn't be happier to be
here with you today thank you it's a
thrill to be here for this very special
day how are you feeling i am thrilled
and i'm relieved because you know when
you start something this big you know
there's always a possibility it might
not work it did work we are so proud
you've been on this project for a very
long time right yeah started in 1995
we had just finished measuring the big
bang we measured it with a cosmic
background explorer satellite that we
built right here at goddard
and we measured the spectrum we've
measured there are hot and cold spots in
the big bang so we said now we know it
all how it all got started but then what
happened after that so then i got a call
from nasa headquarters would i like to
work on this new telescope that's going
to help answer those questions what
happened after the big bang how did the
galaxies grow how did the first black
holes grow
what happened all the way from there to
here so this is our time machine and i
just wanted to be part of it i am so
thrilled that we got a chance to do it
one of the things that i remember you
saying this is kind of amazing that you
after you win the nobel prize you
thought that this mission was the most
important thing to work on absolutely
it's the next question after you know
how it started what happened then
and
you know when suddenly we now have the
technology to do it we didn't have
50 years ago we didn't have the
technology 25 years ago even when we
started this we had to invent things
along the way so we did that and here it
is well thank you we'll be back to you
in just a moment so at the moment we're
going to talk about the way that web is
a completely new way to explore the
universe so today the mission releases
its first science images and gives wings
to the dreams of so many people who
worked so hard for so long to make this
possible for everyone on earth this is
your telescope this is the largest most
powerful observatory ever put into space
it's the product of thousands of people
working for more than two decades this
is a mission that's singularly focused
on the biggest questions in science
so the following phrase is often used
too easily but today actually does mark
the dawn of a new era today the web
mission is open for scientific business
and this is just the beginning the best
is yet to come
so john one of the things you told me
about is that you really want to make
sure there are some people that get
thanked people that put a huge amount of
effort into this absolutely
our current project manager bill oaks
took the project from a time of trouble
when we didn't exactly know how we were
going to get this to work and got it all
the way to the end here it is it is
working and it's because of bill made
this worldwide team 20 000 people around
the world were involved in making this
thing all work and bill has been there
every day
making sure that it would happen
so
another special person is senator
barbara mikulski she saved our telescope
and she saved the telescope before us
she made sure after the hubble telescope
was launched and it was not in focus
that we would go up and fix it she made
sure that happened when the webb
telescope needed more resources she made
sure we could get that so barbara we
thank you
well it is such an honor to be with you
jay i mean it's been a pleasure to be
working with you through this whole
thing thank you so much congratulations
and go webb thank you
so this broadcast much like every part
of this mission is a partnership
on our journey to explore distant places
in space we've been joined by intrepid
travelers from around the globe we have
so many extraordinary collaborators so
let's check in with our partners who
will be sharing the stage with us today
as we reveal webb's five first science
images
from the european space agency i'm
joined by katie haswell in darmstadt
germany katie
i see katie in the background there
also joining us from the canadian space
agency in montreal we have natalie
willett and sarah gallagher bonjour
i see katie in the background there
and so naturally we're also going to be
visiting the nerve center of this
mission the space telescope science
institute on the campus of johns hopkins
university in baltimore maryland and
there we have alex lockwood and carl
gordon and they're going to give us
updates and more good morning
great so we'll be back with our
international partners shortly where
they'll each reveal one of the new
images but today we're also going to be
joined by millions of science fans from
around the world many are gathered at
watch parties just for this event so
here we are really going international
so i'm beginning with bhopal india
do we have a signal from bhopal yes
excellent welcome to nasa hello
everybody there
wonderful to be talking to you today all
the way in india
we'll be back to them later yes great to
wave to you hi wonderful
and we're also we also have a warm
welcome now in portland oregon so we
have the feed from portland
a bit dark but i see anybody there hello
portland
they're an auditorium i see okay okay
next we're going to go off to milan
italy so afternoon in italy do we have
the feed from italy
i guess we have a screen from italy
and next we're going to go to rutland
vermont
so is this vermont hello vermont hi
everybody
nice to see you thank you for being part
of this today
okay going even a little bit further
afield we have natanya israel hello
hello israel yay
really nice to see you guys
okay just one more for now uh i i see
people like giving me hugs
okay we also have vancouver canada hey
vancouver hi all right wonderful
wonderful to have all these people with
you
so right across from the campus for me
there's also a huge watch party taking
place with members of the web team so
the wonderful thing is that they
actually are people that have worked on
the mission and they are part of our
nasa funny stay up the family so hello
hello web team
there they are yes
a lot of people i recognize there
so it's incredibly important to me
personally and also to all of us at nasa
that the universe belongs to everyone
and we are thrilled to share this day
with fans everywhere around the world
we'll say hello to some more later in
our broadcast so now it's time to start
the main event what you'll see over the
next hour will be a collection of images
newly processed by the web science team
only a tiny handful of experts have seen
the images so far and i can tell you
that we have been so excited to unwrap
them for everyone we will be releasing
each image in turn in real time as soon
as you see it on this broadcast it will
be available for download on the
internet on the screen below you can see
a timeline showing where we are in the
show and what's coming up next and by
the end of the show all five images will
be available to everyone
so hopefully you can tell i'm excited
okay so let's do this
okay we're going to release the first
image right here at nasa goddard space
flight center maryland and we're just
outside of washington dc nasa goddard is
home to the project office of the webb
telescope and the observatory portion of
the telescope the mirrors and the
science instruments were integrated and
tested here before launch so for many of
us including myself seeing web come
together bit by bit right in front of
our eyes was an emotional and very
inspiring experience so it's kind of
like a part of us was out there with
webb right now a million miles away part
of our hopes and dreams are out there
so i'm joined now by jane rigby the
operations project scientist for the web
mission and she's a familiar face for
people who've been following this before
so welcome jane hi michelle okay so jane
you not only get the honor of revealing
the first image but this actually got a
little bit of a sneak preview i
understand there was a very select
audience who's already seen the image
yes so last night uh on behalf of the
project i had the privilege of traveling
to the white house uh with the nelson
with the nasa administrator nelson and
other senior staff to share our first
image with president biden and vice
president harris and it it was really
fun oh my gosh um
we're
they really geeked out we had a closed
door session where we got to walk
through all the images and just share
the excitement and they were so thrilled
and they got the profundity of what
we're seeing and so now we're gonna
we're gonna let's do it okay we've got
the whole world watching are you ready
to put the first image up oh let's do it
let's do it
absolutely
all right here we go
okay so the first image is a deep field
and it's also a deep field with a
cluster so why don't we walk through
this just a little bit so if we come up
and look at this image first of all it's
really gorgeous and it's teeming with
galaxies and that's something that has
been true for every image we've gotten
with web we can't take blank sky
everywhere we look there's galaxies
everywhere
and so you know this gal this this image
as we're looking at it what we're seeing
is not just all the galaxies but there's
a cluster here and so the cluster all
these white kind of ethereal galaxies
we're seeing them as they looked back in
time right the speed of light is only so
fast and so as we're seeing distant
galaxies out in space we're seeing them
as they looked billions of years ago so
these cluster galaxies the white ones
were seeing as they looked about the
time the sun and the earth formed
and then behind the cluster we have uh
the cluster the
gravity of the cluster is distorting and
warping our view of what's behind and so
there are these galaxies that look
stretched and pulled kind of like like
they've been magnified because they've
been magnified by the gravity of the
cluster just like einstein said they
would and you know it's really there's
so much detail here we're seeing these
galaxies in a way that we've never been
able to see before there's just a
sharpness and a clarity we've never had
and so we can look at if we zoom in on
this image and i encourage you as you
grab this image at home like zoom in it
you can you know really zoom in and play
around there are galaxies here in which
you're seeing individual clusters of
stars forming popping up just like
popcorn
and then
we also see in the background of the
scallop of this image kind of littered
like jewels all over the back of the
image are these faint
red galaxies
now that was what we built the telescope
to do
the most distant of those are
billions of years we're seeing as they
looked more than 13 billion years ago
and so galaxies like that one right
there this little red guy you're like
okay yep what is that well webb got
spectra to figure out what those
galaxies are made of and this is that
one we're seeing as it looked 13.1
billion years in the past less than a
billion years after the big bang and
we're seeing the elements of oxygen and
hydrogen as well as neon you know this
is the kind this is how the oxygen in
our bodies was made in stars in galaxies
and we're seeing that process get
started yeah i just i want to give this
a little bit of context so
this is now the farthest away galaxy
that we have this sort of detailed
information about that we know what it's
made we know what it's made of
and this was not a long exposure for web
no the the the the private the previous
record holder right the hubble of
extreme deep field was two weeks of
continuous work with hubble and it was
just imaging with web we took that image
before breakfast
the amazing thing about web is the speed
at which we can churn out discoveries so
everything that you're going to see here
in this broadcast is
a week and we're going to be doing
discoveries like this every week
that is absolutely incredible jane so
thank you so much for joining us i it's
an honor to be working with you
congratulations on all your hard work
thank you it's so wonderful to see it
pay off
so thank you and i'll see you later on
today i hope so enjoy the day thank you
right
so from distant galaxies we now turn our
eye to something a bit closer it's a
planet but not one in our solar system
remember that earth and its sibling
planets aren't the only show in the
universe when scientists and engineers
started developing jwst the search for
exoplanets wasn't even part of the plan
that's changed
exploring exoplanets is now a major
component of the mission and the subject
of our second big reveal of the day
i'm going to send it down to our friends
natalie willette and sarah gallagher at
the canadian space agency in montreal so
again bonjour
i guess we're having a little
ball okay
and i'm here to tell you
sorry for the brief pause there we're
now going over to canada
yep we're all ready yeah sorry
okay i apologize we're having some
trouble with the signal from canada but
luckily for us we have an exoplanet
expert right here just in case that
happened so this is nicole colon and
she's an exoplanet scientist at nasa and
we're going to talk about this amazing
new result from a very hot planet i
understand about a thousand light years
away that's right the exoplanet is named
wasp 96b
and it is this hot gaseous giant puffy
planet that it is about a thousand light
years away so that's why today's release
is so exciting
absolutely so talk us through what this
discovery is and why this is so
significant
well this uh reveal that you're going to
see is going to show the first spectrum
of an exoplanet as taken from the webb
telescope and this is exciting because
it covers infrared wavelengths of light
that we have not had access to
before so we've been able to use other
telescopes to explore exoplanet
atmospheres in the infrared but not to
this level of detail and this is just
one sliver
of data that web is providing us using
the nearest instrument specifically and
there's something about um infrared that
is actually particularly good for the
spectrum so in this in this case what
we're doing is we're actually going to
take the light and break it up into a
rainbow and look very very carefully at
how much color is coming in each cut in
each part of the spectrum so i believe
we have that image if we can put that up
okay yes i i believe we're revealing the
spectrum right here so we now have our
spectrum and this is exactly what you're
seeing as you just described with
spectroscopy what we did was we observed
a transit of an exoplanet we observed
the planet as it passed in front of the
star now mind you this is not a direct
image this is an indirect image so we've
seen the effect of what happens when the
planet and its atmosphere passes in
front of the star the starlight filters
through the atmosphere and then you can
break that down into wavelengths of
light and you get a bunch of what looks
like bumps and wiggles to some people
but it's actually full of information
content so you're actually seeing bumps
and wiggles that indicate the presence
of water vapor in the atmosphere of this
exoplanet
so we have the spectrum up here is there
anything you'd like to highlight
particularly
yeah absolutely so we have
several features marked here so i call
them features they are these what i just
referred to as bumps and wiggles but
what you're seeing here is the telltale
signature the chemical fingerprint of
water vapor in these atmospheres in the
in the atmosphere of this specific
exoplanet and the other thing we can
tell actually is that there's evidence
of clouds and hazes because the water
features are not quite as large as we
predicted so we can take that and infer
that there are presence of clouds and
hazes right now one thing that we really
want to make sure people understand is
with this particular planet this is a
hot world it's actually closer to its
star than mercury is to our sun and so
we're not looking at liquid water here
but we're looking at that sort of steam
water vapor yes this is a an exoplanet
it's about the size of jupiter about
half the mass of jupiter it orbits
around a sun-like star but it does it
every about three and a half days so
it's extremely hot extremely closely
nothing like our solar system planets
but that's okay
because what we're seeing
is again the first exoplanet data from
web and this is just the beginning we're
going to start pushing down to further
smaller planets and being able to take
measurements just like this with the
nearest instrument that was built by the
canadian space agency but also there's
other three three other science
instruments that will add to our
knowledge in the infrared as well as
direct imaging modes along with the
transit method so there's a lot more to
come and i guess one thing we should
mention is not only are we going to be
looking at planets that are more like
the earth in the future but we'll also
be looking at planets in our own solar
system absolutely yes we're going to
have exciting data from planets in our
solar system from mars
outward as well as asteroids and comets
so stay tuned for a lot more to come
thank you so much nicole thank you so
much for telling us about the spectrum
and i'll be seeing you later on today
so we have three more big image reveals
and with that new and more exciting
science but first let's take a look back
at the journey that brought us to this
moment
celebrations on this one are only
possible with years of hard work from a
cast of thousands when a new mission is
being built even the most enthusiastic
space fans only get to see dramatic
moments in this life cycle the news and
images that come out of updates and
press releases
but that doesn't really give you the
sense of the huge effort that goes on
behind the scenes every day
the plan schedules an organization to
keep everything moving forward really
happens for the most part out of
people's gaze
web started as an idea that took root at
nasa goddard a group first into planning
teams research projects schematics
requirements then it began the long
journey to become real with the
development of new technologies cutting
edge engineering and finally fabrication
putting it all together
let's take a brief look back at the
visionary journey to how we all got here
today
so today was the
final close out of the purge okay guys i
can hear rupa but pretty emotional
moment to be in there and actually you
know closing it up for the very last
time right you know you're the last one
to touch this and
so that was the final operation and once
that fitting is closed out um there's no
more touching of the vehicle we're ready
for launch
[Music]
the james webb space telescope
born from the desires of astronomers
achieved with newly invented technology
is the culmination of 20 years of work
humanity has unlimited questions about
our universe engineering a way to
investigate them requires enormous
creativity
web has been a trade-off between
engineering performance what the
astronomers want
risk in fact when we started 20 years
ago we were actually looking at an eight
meter telescope developing the most
sensitive instruments
and testing
and more testing
and so you don't want to build one
that's just incrementally better than
what you've got
because if that's the case you would
just observe longer on the telescope
that you already got and so every time
nasa builds a new astrophysics mission a
new telescope it needs to be
way more sensitive you know way more
capable than anything we've ever built
before
we all got together in that conference
room and we played real time as the
images came down
from the spacecraft
the very first diffraction limited
images
ever obtained with webb and what we
collectively saw as a group
was the highest resolution
infrared image
taken from space ever
if you're just joining us i'm michelle
thaller at nasa's goddard space flight
center and you are watching live
coverage of the release of the first
science images from the james webb space
telescope
so it's appropriate now that i send the
broadcast to our colleagues and friends
at the space telescope science institute
in baltimore that's the scientific nerd
center of the entire web mission so
hello good morning alex the show is
yours
hey michelle
welcome to the space telescope science
institute i'm alex lockwood and i'm here
with carl gordon who is an astronomer
and one of the
key people in delivering the images that
you're going to see here today
but actually before we get into the
amazing images we're going to talk a
little bit about where we are
we're standing here outside of the
mission operations center
which is the key central hub for web
for the past six months scientists and
engineers have been working 24 7 since
they took control of the telescope 30
minutes after launch to prepare for
today
and for the amazing science to come
through all of the major deployments
focusing aligning the telescope and
calibrating those four amazing science
instruments it was all done in this
building and from here on out we'll have
daily communications with the telescope
including sending commands and
downloading data with the help of the
deep space network
in addition to mission operations we are
also the home of science operations well
what does that mean
every year we solicit proposals from
astronomers across the country for and
the world for what they would like to
look at with web
then we hold a rigorous selection
process to select the ideas that will
best utilize web to study and understand
our universe
when the data come down and astronomers
analyze their results
we are the lucky ones who get to share
that data and those amazing science
results with you
and we knew that today was going to be
so exciting with the first images so
we've actually been preparing for years
here is klaus pontapidin project
scientist for web and the technical lead
for the first image that's been a year
to tell you about the process of the
past
my first email related to the uh the
first images was back from 2016.
so back then
a committee was created and this
committee was charged with
coming up with a long list
of targets for the first images
and the reason for that is that the
observatory can't see the entire sky
at any given time
and this is because you want to avoid
the mirror
seeing direct sunlight to keep it cold
it actually had to be quite a long list
we ended up with about 70 targets
from which we had to select only a
handful
you know what would create the most
beautiful images what would highlight
the instruments
the four different four science
instruments for web and what would
highlight the four
major science themes for web and it's a
celebration as well of the beginning of
science observations
and we knew that selecting the images
was just the beginning that we would
need a trained eye to take these
exquisite data and pull out the beauty
and the science potential
so here's jodi pasqual and elisa pagan
to tell you about how they processed
these beautiful images
[Music]
we're basically translating light that
we can't see into light that we can see
by applying uh color like red green and
blue to the different filters that we
have from web
and the reason we want to color the
images is because there's actually more
that you can get more information that
you can get from the image if you see it
in color so it's a matter of picking and
choosing filters and colors that enhance
the details and the structure in the
image itself
the shortest wavelengths of infrared
light and assign those blue colors
and then move our way down to green and
red as we go to longer and longer
wavelengths and then we additively
combine those together to get our full
color image
but there is a lot of aesthetics that
are involved in this painstakingly going
through and cleaning these images up
with an attention to detail level of
detail like at the pixel level in every
image
so when i'm working on
the astronomical data it is this sort of
marriage between art and science when
you're choosing colors for the filters
you really are trying to show the
different details and the processes that
are happening in astronomical images but
at the end of the day you want it to be
very compelling you want it to be very
beautiful because space is beautiful
and after those images were processed
there was a select few of us very lucky
few of us who got to see the first
images
[Music]
so just to make it a little more and
more handy so it's actually higher
resolution
so we have a team of about 30 people who
are producing these images and we feel
incredibly privileged to be the ones
who are the first to see these
science-like images
when when we saw the first data come
down of real targets
people were speechless and there were
emotions
because we immediately we could see
how amazing this observatory would be
the detail the sharpness the depth
and when we saw the first color images
we knew that we had a winner
[Music]
and now
we are ready to see webb's first image
of star dying a planetary nebula called
the southern ring
let's do it
wow
wow this this near infrared image is
wow the detail
wow okay well here we are we have a near
infrared image on our left or on maybe
your right
and here on the right we have a
near-infrared image um and so
i'm here with carl our our astronomer uh
specialist can you tell us what we're
looking at in these images so this is a
planetary nebula it's caused by a dying
star that has expelled a large fraction
of its mass over in successive waves
okay so we actually see those waves in
these images yes
um wow wow and so there's a lot of
structure can you tell us a little more
detail about what we're looking maybe
start with this one on the left yeah so
in the in the near cam image you see
this kind of bubbly uh you know almost
foamy appearance throughout the whole
nebula with some very structured
shells but and this foaminess is showing
up in orange mainly and this is this is
due to the molecular hydrogen that's
newly formed in the expansion uh just
lighting up the gas and dust of this
nebula
and then as we move inward you see this
kind of very uh blue haze in the inner
region and this is actually due to very
hot ionized gas that emits well in the
blue
that's heated by the core the leftover
very hot core of this star
and what about these like rays that i'm
seeing in this image right there so
there's also rays in the outer regions
that you can kind of see and these are
holes in the inner nebula that are
actually allowing the the central star's
lights to come out and kind of light it
up like you know patchy clouds with the
sun shining through wow oh yeah that's
what it looks like that's so cool
um so you're actually a mid-infrared
astronomer which is different than
near-infrared and so what can you tell
us about the details in this
mid-infrared image so this is it looks
quite different in color
partly because we're seeing different
kinds of physics going on here so we're
actually seeing in the blue you see a
lot of blue the blue is actually due to
hydrocarbon grains that are emitting
very strongly in the blue for mary and
they show the very similar structures to
what we see in orange near cam because
the the hydrocarbon the
molecular hydrocarbon actually forms on
the surface of dust grains and so again
as we move inward we we see that the
inner region is again hot ionized gas
but now it glows red because that's
where it emits longest for the strongest
for miri wavelengths okay and then as we
go into the center we see kind of the
surprise for us which is we knew this
was a binary star but we basi we
effectively didn't really see much of
this of the the actual star that
produced the nebula but now in miri this
star glows red because it has dust
around it so in miri we got to see both
stars very clearly yeah yeah you can't
see it in first image really but there's
two stars there
so that's a fun surprise um and i think
that there's another little easter egg
you want to tell us about yeah so this
was uh the easter egg is this kind of
narrow filament up in the up in the top
that's radially aligned you can kind of
see it very clearly in the mirror image
it shows up as this blue blue structure
and it points very much to the central
sources so i thought oh this must just
be a density enhancement in the outer
nebula i thought that very very strongly
but other people on the team were like
no it's a background edge on galaxy well
i made a bet that said no it's part of
the nebula by the way i lost the bet
because then we looked more carefully at
both the near cam and miri images and
it's very clearly an edge-on galaxy with
a dust lane and a bulge so i lost the
bet
well you lost a bet but you got these
gorgeous images so i think it's a win
for everybody
anything else you'd like to say today i
can't wait to see where we go from here
oh neither can i alright thanks so much
back to you michelle
[Music]
thank you alex and carl and i have to
say that image is absolutely spectacular
so as you know people from all over the
world are watching us today and joining
in in our excitement as we release for
webb's first science images we've been
checking in with our colleagues in
europe and canada throughout the program
but we also want to take a moment to
include the people at the oh so many
viewing parties scattered around the
world like stars in the night sky so
let's check in with some of them now
first we go all the way to perth
australia do we have a signal from birth
i guess nothing from perth right now
maybe we have some of our other feeds
we're going to check in with them right
now
do we have winnipeg canada
oh there it is there's australia there's
perth hey
waving to perth australia thank you so
much for joining us today
and next we're going to winnipeg
winnipeg canada
hello winnipeg
at a planetarium everybody's enjoying
the show i hope
okay dayton ohio
everybody's watching on the uh
there we go dayton ohio hello everybody
dayton nice to have you here with us
there we go yes
hey
hey dayton hey
they're jumping up and down
hi
okay all the way bangalore india india
bangalore
hello hello hello to bangalore india hey
it's absolutely wonderful hey
okay
so i i hope you enjoy the the rest of
the images we're releasing
okay of course nasa's family extends all
over the country the team at jpl and
passed you to california they're on site
to celebrate with us so hello jbl
some of my favorite people in the world
hey hello
and i think the last place we're going
to right now is north of grumman one of
our major contractors hello north and
from
oh hey all right
yay
nice to see you northrop grumman
all right now there's also a big watch
party right here on the nasa goddard
campus many of these people have worked
on the mission itself we also top nasa
leadership and representatives from our
government so hello
hello watch party at goddard yay
okay wonderful so i mean at nasa we are
so fortunate to have all of these
friends and colleagues around the globe
a major partner in the web mission is
the european space agency esa
contributions have been essential to so
many aspects of this project including
webb's spectacular launch on the ariane
5 rocket last december i'm very pleased
to turn over the show for a few minutes
to katie haswell she's joining me from
the european space operations center in
darmstadt germany hello katie good
afternoon
thanks michelle
thank you michelle and welcome to
germany we're at the
european union space i'm still getting
all kinds of isp from water
that's where the teams effectively fly
the satellites they're a little bit of a
cross between air traffic controllers
and pilots we have lots of different
control rooms here this is the
main control room and as you can see
today it's not in use so we've been
lucky enough to
move in here for today i have two very
special um experts with me both
scientists from the european space
agency uh
giovanna giardino is a near-spec
scientist giovanna
is uh has been working on that for for
many years and lots to tell us about
that and mark mccorkan is a special
advisor for space for science and
exploration these two guys have been
working on the web space telescope for a
long time so we're very grateful to have
you with us thanks folks
and we we are excited to reveal our
image with you but before we do that we
thought give you a little bit of
background um because we've come here
today uh because these guys were the
first ones uh to pick up the signal
uh during the
web launch when web first launched
they run a system called s track which
is nasa's deep space
tracking system and they were listening
out
when webb called home and the
controllers here have been looking after
a whole very very impressive list of
missions
since
1968
issa has played a very very important
role during the web for the web space
telescope they provided the launch on
board the awesome ariane 5 launch
vehicle from the guiana space center the
atmosphere in the mission control center
it was
electric i can tell you i was there and
they've also provided people we have 15
eso scientists working at a space
telescope in baltimore and also they
have provided the um
infrared
spectrograph
the near infrared spectrograph and also
half of the meri instrument which is the
mid infrared instrument let's take a
look at those now
webb's four scientific instruments
include near spec the near infrared
spectrograph led by issa
nirspec splits near infrared light from
astronomical objects into its components
like a barcode this will help scientists
understand the physics of the objects
they're observing from their temperature
to atomic makeup
nearspec can observe parts of an object
or the sky using an image slicer and an
array of microscopic shutters
webb's integrated science instrument
module located behind the main mirror
also contains miri a mid mid-infrared
camera and spectrograph
seen here during testing
miri has been developed by a partnership
between europe and the us
miri detects mid-infrared light from
planets stars and galaxies it can
analyze molecules to help us deduce what
astronomical objects are made of and
peer into clouds of gas and dust where
stars and planets are born
together these instruments will help
webb detect and analyze light from the
very dawn of time
revealing the universe as never before
so
so let's get ready to reveal our image
and remember that one of webb's jobs is
to find out about galaxies
more about the galaxies but also to help
us to understand how they change and
this image is going to be very very
useful for that let's reveal it now
there it is it's called stefan's quintet
and it's wondrous
giovanna what are we looking at
yes like it's a quintet so we are
looking at five galaxies
galaxies are uh this giant structure
that as we've seen we see everywhere
around us in the universe that contains
from million to 100 billions of stars
and in fact we live in one of them the
milky way and here we see five of them
this is a
closer um galaxy in the foreground and
these four are at a distance of about uh
300
million light years from us and they're
locked in a close interaction a sort of
cosmic dance driven by the gravitational
force
you can see here these two uh in a
process of merging
within each other this is a very
important image
an area to study because it really shows
the type of interaction that drives the
evolution of galaxy that
that's the mechanism our galaxy's growth
i love this image of the cosmic dance
moving through each other uh mark
there's a lot going on though in this
image isn't there there is so this is a
near-infrared image and a mid-infrared
infrared image combined and when we zoom
in on the left-hand side here we see
this foreground galaxy you see lots of
individual stars in there actually
resolved as point sources which is
remarkable then as we pan across we
actually see the the galaxies in the the
merging galaxies we now see gas and dust
which is being heated up in the
collision between those galaxies and
that's place where new stars are being
born today so we're actually seeing the
process of creation of new stars in this
region and then when we look in the
background here we see not only the
galaxies at 300 million light years but
also stars in our own galaxy these
snowflake structures that you see here
those are nearby stars but in the corner
and around the edges we see galaxies
which are much much more distant much
further away so similar in some sense to
the ones that we saw earlier on in that
deep field and so this image actually
takes us from the nearby galaxy our own
milky way through these galaxies which
are evolving today all the way to the
distant universe and in a way it
captures
cosmic evolution of galaxies over those
13.8 billion years
so we have another image don't we that
we can exactly so so if we strip away
the near-infrared view there of the
stars predominantly now in the
mid-infrared with miri alone we see
mostly gas and dust so we've seen the
same galaxies again the two merging and
then we also see something very
interesting up at the top here because
this top galaxy has something new and
bright in the middle of it and giovanna
tell us what that is yeah that's an
active black hole
we cannot see the black hole itself but
we see the material swirling around
being swallowed by these sort of cosmic
monsters
and gets
this gas gets heated to extremely high
temperature as it falls onto the black
hole and it becomes very bright in fact
this is how chinese the galaxy we see
luminosity that are 40 billion times the
luminosity of our sounds is really
really bright and with nilspec we can
zoom
into this area and we have this
technology that allows us to take
thousands of images different wavelength
channels
uh so see the uh
the this distribution of the gas was
going on in the gas uh in different
region uh of the of this core area and
understand the composition of the gas
the velocities um the temperature so
that's very important to understand the
physics so it's giving us so much
information it just shows the power of
this telescope mark
this is just the beginning though isn't
it i think that's a very important
takeaway from today you know we these
are like pictures just taken over a
period of five days and every five days
we're getting more data which will
contribute more in that in that
direction it's a culmination of decades
of work but it's just the beginning of
decades and you know what we've seen
today with these images is essentially
that we're ready now this telescope is
working fantastically well and you know
to to borrow a phrase from a famous rock
musician you know we're ready to turn
this telescope up to 11. it really is
time it's fantastic
thank you very much indeed both of you
back to you michelle
thanks katie it is so great to have you
and your colleagues with us on this
historic day
so before we get to the fifth and final
image reveal of the day it cannot be
said enough that an achievement like the
james webb space telescope is something
bigger than any one of us it's bigger
than any organization any country this
truly takes a planet web belongs to all
of us and starting today the discoveries
start and they're not going to stop this
is just the beginning
we've said several times throughout the
broadcast that the web mission is about
people and during the construction of
the great telescope people started to
see themselves in it literally
day after day people visited the
observation window at nasa goddard and
looking through the glass they snapped
selfies of themselves reflected in the
gigantic golden mirror
these photos are actual reflections of
the enormous human investment and the
emotional commitment that brought this
mission to life
and now years later that mission is
finally collecting light from the
earliest days of the universe all the
way to worlds in our own solar system
it's the same mirror that reflected the
many faces who see themselves as part of
the journey to understand our shared
origins
let's stop for a moment and appreciate
the people behind webb
okay it's time now for the last image to
be revealed here we go
so amber strawn is webb's deputy project
scientist he's here with me today to
share the final big reveal of the day so
amber it is so good to see you how are
you feeling oh
so great so exciting what a what a great
day this is yeah so one of the things
that we're going to do is before we get
to the final image the james webb space
telescope has taken us all over the
universe today so let's do a quick
review of where we've been so far
so jane rigby got us rolling today with
an extraordinary new deep field image
showing us one of the farthest views of
the universe ever yeah this image really
does demonstrate that jwst can do
exactly what we've designed it to do yes
and uh the canadian space agency then
took us to the massive planet wasp 96b
where the team has detected evidence of
atmospheric water
and here again we're seeing the
incredible efficiency of this
observatory we're able to do these kind
of measurements in a fraction of the
time that we are were able to before
and then we zipped at the road from nasa
goddard to the space telescope science
institute where alex and carl showed us
the exquisite southern ring nebula a
mixing bowl of stellar matter around a
pair of dying stars yeah and i'm just
blown away by the level of detail we can
see like in the outer part of this
nebula it's incredible wow okay after
that it was off to germany where the
european space agency wowed us with
pictures of galaxies interacting and
mixing together right and this image
again it's just it's incredible because
it's showing us one of these fundamental
processes of the universe how galaxies
merge together and we're able to learn
about these processes in a brand new way
so the web team has a lot to cheer about
right now so across the campus there's
this big watch party and we can feel the
excitement all the way from over here so
let's join that celebration now we're
back with senior project scientist john
mather along with the head of nasa's
science mission directorate thomas
booken hello
so uh john we looked around the world
and we're the only ones with a
cheerleading
crew like over there that's amazing uh
look uh you've been with this mission
for decades
uh how do you feel today i am so
thrilled and so relieved this was so
hard
and we took it took so long um it's just
impossible to convey how hard it really
was
that we risked so much to say we're
going to go do this and it's so nearly
impossible but we did it yeah there are
thousands way thousands of ways this can
go wrong many of them uh you know we
worried about and frankly feared even
after launch have to tell you i was
really really nervous and you know it's
almost like athletics for me you always
get to know the team when they're on the
field and on the field they were right
after this launch and they were perfect
they absolutely were and i really wasn't
worried but maybe i should have been
yeah that's that's difference between
the two of us i always worry i always
tell everybody i'm paid to worry uh
frankly uh and and and that's good uh
what we want to do though is you know
just really thank the team again you
know of course we heard uh bill and
scott and greg talking about the team
that was there i think what's also
important is to recognize that bernie is
sitting there it was the first manager i
was sitting there could you stand up
and
uh and i want to mention that phil sable
house who is a manager also during that
time is no longer with us but his heart
is with us today
yeah
i have to tell you i have to tell you
john after each one of these milestones
i called a lot of people i called bernie
for example and i called uh people at my
job and people who are administrators
because there's many of them and i just
wonder how you feel about the team to
stack give you the word here i am just
so thrilled that we had a privilege to
assemble such a brilliant team
we drew from the best of the best and
here we are
so my
extreme deep thanks go to all the people
who built that team not only to bernie
who started us and helped us build up
all the technology to phil who made sure
we would have a plan
and then when we didn't have quite
enough money to build who pulled it all
together and made it get all the way to
the end i am so thrilled that we had so
much talent to draw on and here we are
we have the support of the country and
the world to take on this immense
challenge
you know what i'm most excited about
there's tens of thousands of scientists
and frankly some of them just got born
or not even born
who are benefiting from this amazing
telescope because it will be with us for
decades it will be and we have it took
us about 25 years to get here since 1995
and we have at least 25 to go i hope so
look uh we are in a sense of of these
images the art that is out there in the
sky revealed for the first time we're
thinking of the team and we're thanking
them john thanks to you thanks to all of
you and back to michelle
thank you so much thomas and this entire
collection continues to just absolutely
astound me
okay amber so here it is can you walk us
through the final image reveal
absolutely here we go
the last image is
wow look at that
so amber can you can you tell us a bit
about what we're seeing here of course
this stunning vista of the cosmic cliffs
of the karina nebula reveals new details
about this vast stellar nursery today
for the first time we're seeing brand
new stars that were previously
completely hidden from our view
there's something you want to point out
here absolutely so
honestly it took me a while to even
figure out what to call out in this
image there's just so much going on here
it's so beautiful one thing that really
really stands out to me is you sort of
get this sense of depth and texture from
this new data um there's just there's a
lot going on to call out a few specifics
first of all in general the karina
nebula is a nearby star forming region
within our own milky way galaxy about 7
600 light years away
and in this view we see some great
examples first of all of hundreds of new
stars that we've never seen before we
see examples of bubbles and cavities and
jets that are being blown out by these
newborn stars we even see some galaxies
sort of lurking in the background up
here we see examples of structures that
honestly we don't even know what they
are like what's going on here there's
just there's the data is just so rich
and there's something really special
about the infrared infrared can actually
see deeper into these star-forming
regions absolutely that's one of the
great things about infrared is it really
does reveal
what's going on here in a really cosmic
sense and in general what's happening in
sort of this overall landscape is we
have these gigantic hot young stars up
here to the top of this rim and the
radiation and stellar winds from those
stars is sort of pushing down and
running into all of this this is gas and
dust and of course we know that gas and
dust is great raw material for newborn
stars and baby planets but there's a
flip side to this story and also a
little bit of a mystery because these
same processes can serve to sort of
erode away this material and stop star
formation so we have this sort of
delicate balance going on of new stars
being formed but at the same time the
star formation is being halted
and for me
when i see an image like this i can't
help but think about scale you know
every dot of light we see here is an
individual star
not unlike our sun
and many of these likely also have
planets and it just reminds me that you
know our sun and our planets and
ultimately us were formed out of the
same kind of stuff that we see here
we humans really are connected to the
universe we're made of the same stuff in
this beautiful landscape and actually
the created nebula was one of my
favorite images from hubble so have a
look at this as well right absolutely
yeah yeah the hubble image of this is
also spectacular we saw it in a
different kind of light when hubble
took an image of this of this particular
nebula and then you can see amazing
things with hubble but when we zoom in
to this new image we're able to see so
much more detail and of course all of us
you know i grew up
on hubble and all of us love hubble and
i'm just i'm so excited to see what
these two amazing observatories are able
to do really in tandem with each other
thank you so much and again
congratulations it's been a pleasure to
be working on this with you i'm just
amazed by what's been going on i am too
thank you
so as we're wrapping up one of the
things that i really have to say is the
the the journey that we've been going on
is so very dramatic for me so we've gone
all the way from the birth of stars and
we have all the way from the distant
galaxies to the birth of stars this is
where we all began this was the whole
point of the james webb space telescope
to figure out our origins from the very
very early days of the universe to star
and planet formation very nearby
so right now i'm very honored to have
our last special guest this is the
administrator of nasa bill nelson an
honor to be with you sir
hey what a pleasure what what a banner
day
it's clear that webb represents
the best of nasa
it maintains
our ability to propel us forward
for science
for risk-taking
for inspiration
and we don't want to ever stop exploring
the heavens nor stop daring to take
another step forward for humanity
in the words of the famous carl sagan
somewhere
something incredible is waiting to be
known
i think those words are becoming reality
absolutely thanks michelle an honor to
have you here thank you very much
wow
so
this is a celebration for all humanity
if you've ever looked up at the night
sky and wonder whoever you are wherever
you are
this is your telescope
and we also salute the thousands of
people who have dedicated part of their
lives to making web a reality
i also want to give a big shout out for
the superb media team who's helping web
story to the world this broadcast is a
joint effort of the superstar producers
animators and social media specialists
at the canadian space agency isa nasa
and especially the goddard space flight
center
webb captures light in distant colors
that the eye can't see and you've
actually made this visible to the world
so finally if you go to nasa.gov web
first images you can download all of the
images and data we've just shown in full
resolution and check back often from now
on we share new discoveries exciting new
destinations around the universe
july 12 2022 marks a huge day for
science it's only just the beginning
for everyone at csa esa and nasa i'm so
very pleased you could join us i'm
michelle thought
go web
[Music]
[Music]
you